good morning everyone I'm really excited
to be here I think so far this
conference and the talks and everybody
has been pretty awesome now it's my turn
so I still have time to ruin it but
hopefully the next 35 minutes are gonna
be just fine so yeah what I'm going to
talk about today is machine learning for
front-end devs
so hopefully for you so I know I've
already been introduced in you know the
most magnificent way but yes my name is
Charlie Jerrod I am a developer at a
company called Atlassian in Sydney if
you don't know the name Atlassian you
might know the products that we work on
we have our conference bit back here and
JIRA so I started I started working
there a couple of weeks ago and I'm
already here and I haven't fired me yet
so I think they're pretty cool so far
but outside of my job I'm also a Google
developer expert and a Mozilla tech
Speaker I think Jing mentioned yesterday
what it's about but yes so I'm part of
these two of these two groups of people
who like to share knowledge as well the
another thing that is more important to
know about me in this particular talk is
that I'm not an expert in machine
learning so it is a bit weird me here
talking to you about how to do stuff
when I'm actually not an expert but
that's probably the main reason why I
wanted to give this talk is because
machine learning can kind of feel a bit
scary at first you kind of like what is
this kind of new world am I even gonna
be able to do this and I'm here to tell
you that if I can do that on my own time
and build little prototypes then anybody
in this room can to and to me that's
what matters and the other point is that
it means that everything that I'm gonna
explain in this presentation I tried to
make it as clear as possible for any
JavaScript dev to understand I don't
have a background in data science so I
didn't put any kind of like fancy words
so let's start with what is machine
learning obviously I don't know what you
know I don't know so I thought that
before studying into like talking about
concepts and code samples I think I
should start with an example so instead
of just a definition so if we think
about something as common as you know
figuring out spam emails for example so
I guess we all receive spam emails and
if we don't think about the machine
learning way and we try to think about
the way we would solve that problem in
traditional programming so what do we
know about spam emails they are usually
about a certain topic so you could look
for words like viagra or lottery or you
know
a prince you know all of a sudden I get
a lot of princes you know like sending
me emails and so you know that you would
be able to check your new emails and
maybe look for certain words like these
words in particular the problem with
that is that it's not really something
that is really productive or efficient
because it means that you don't have to
keep a list of up-to-date words that you
know are in spam emails and if you think
about the word viagra it can be written
like so many different times like I sort
of like it weighs sorry so you could
have spaces between the letters you
could have a a for instead of the a like
people get really creative when they
want to spam you so instead that's
obviously pseudocode right but you can
have you can think of machine learning
in a way where you would import what we
call a model so what you would use
emails that you've received before in
the past some that have already been
classified between spam or not spam and
using that data you would use algorithms
to find patterns in what makes a spam
email and then once this model is
created you'll be able to load it in
your app get a new email and let the
model decide or predict the probability
of the new email being a spam or not so
it's basically the ability to if you
give the ability to computers to figure
out patterns in data without telling you
exactly what to look for you're not
going to tell it to look for the word
viagra you're just gonna give it a lot
of emails and let it just figure out by
itself so this is kind of like the
baseline and what I mentioned is that
you want to create a model that's at the
core of machine learning and models are
created with algorithms so when I talk
about algorithms I'm not talking about
you know quicksort and stuff like that
machine learning has you know its own
types of algorithms so here are just a
few examples that are you know quite
common if you start reading about
machine learning like tutorials and
things like that the K nearest neighbor
or a convolutional neural network and so
all of these are algorithms kind of are
better at different things they are they
fit kind of different purposes but
before picking your algorithm to solve a
problem you actually have to understand
what type of problem you're trying to
solve and so let's copy that so you have
three main ones you have supervised
learning and supervised learning and
reinforcement learning you might
sometimes hear as well about
semi-supervised the for the
of this particular talk we're only going
to cover supervised and unsupervised
first of all because I have 30 only 35
minutes and also because a lot of the
problems that you'll want to solve can
be solved with these two types of
learning reinforcement learning usually
is more if you want to work on a
self-driving car or stuff like that okay
I can safely assume I mean if you're
working on similar and Cassidy's awesome
you probably don't need that talk at all
but other people if it's your first time
you probably can't fix your your
problems with supervised and
unsupervised so let's dig into it so
supervised learning is the creative
creation of a predictive model based on
a set of features and labels so if it's
only that definition like that it might
not really make sense but there's three
important things in this one so what is
a predictive model and then what we mean
by features and labels so for it to make
a bit more sense I thought I would you
know talk with an example and a classic
example of a supervised learning problem
is predicting the price of a house so
let's imagine well we're doing is let's
say we have a house and we want to sell
it but we don't really know how much to
sell it for for it to be sold quite fast
but what we do know or what we could
have access to is data of all the houses
in Vilnius and their price so in this
particular case the label is the price
it's what you're trying to predict is
how you would classify each entry in
your data set the particular thing
features would be the characteristics of
the entries in your data set so for a
house it would be the number of rooms
maybe the number of floors number of
bathrooms does it have a garden where is
it and things like that and using this
data set of features and labels you
would pick an algorithm that would learn
the correlation between pitches and
labels and create the predictive model
so in the end a model is just a
mathematical representation of the
outcome of your training it's kind of
like a function that you call and you
pass it new data it's never seen before
and some parameters and it's able to
predict a price for a house it's never
seen before based on the pattern that
it's seen from previous data so
supervised learning you know on the kind
of theoretical level is like that but
then unsupervised learning is the
ability to create predictions based only
on a set of features and the end of that
definition is really important because
that's what makes the difference it's
only the set of features and if we think
about our example of
predicting the price of a house that
wouldn't really work because if you just
give it the number of bedrooms and
bathrooms how do you want it to figure
out a price if it's never seen it before
so another example for that particular
case of unsupervised learning it's more
around predicting customer behavior or
buying patterns so if you think about
when you go to the grocery store it's
really easy for them or even for your
bank to know what you buy when which
shopping center and things like that
and based on so that would be the
features for each customer and what you
would use in supervised learning for is
more clustering people together that's
at the core of unsupervised learning you
don't try to predict a really specific
output you try to cluster people
together and you could use that for
things like advertising for example
based on what I buy it would be easy to
cluster me with a certain type of people
even without knowing me at all
personally they would probably can
figure out that I'm young they could
figure out that I'm a woman that they
would know where I live and based on who
I would be clustered with it would be
really easy for them to know what I
might like to buy so that is you know
the type of stuff that you can do with
unsupervised learning you know instead
of just looking about that I thought I
would also show applications of what you
can do so let's cover a few if he wants
that I found that I came across so the
first one is something that I think it
was probably the first experiment that I
saw using JavaScript for machine
learning it was made by Sarah Dresner I
need an experiment where you can upload
a picture and have machine learning
generates the alt text for you so you
know it's just like something that you
try to do and you might think about like
well you know I can do it myself you
know if it's one picture but you could
think about how that kind of tools could
be helpful in your development process
if you have if you need to actually
generate it for a lot of images instead
of having a dev you know having to
figure out how to best describe an image
you could just give it to machine
learning algorithms and then you could
move on to doing things that you might
want to work more on like solving
problems that you think would be more
interesting so that's just one of the
one of the examples another one that I
really like is a filtering unwanted
content so I'm not safe for work GS is a
framework where you can also upload a
picture and it would give you the
probability of it being content that is
kind of risky to show on your website
and maybe you're like you know what why
would I even do that so I think it was I
mean to me it was really interesting
because before being they've actually
worked in advertising I was a digital
producer so sometimes when you work for
brands you they want to put together
competitions where people upload you
know customers upload the pictures and
then people can vote and then you win
and you have a free trip kind of thing
but the thing is usually you people want
to upload and see that picture live like
right away on the website like on a
gallery of images and you know when you
produce that kind of campaign you want
to make sure that people don't upload
like naked pics or something so if that
kind of thing would be it could be like
a layer before the picture is actually
uploaded to the database instead of
having a developer or any team member
actually sitting down and scrolling
through all the pictures you could
actually leverage machine learning to do
that for you and where it gets even more
interesting is things around
accessibility so that's why I'm really
glad that we talked about accessibility
yesterday because I really believe that
you can actually use innovative
technology and machine learning to help
people in some ways so I don't know if
you came across that project but this a
developer here I'm gonna say his name
really badly but it's a Abhishek thing
and I'll put a link to his blog post so
you can check it out but the concept was
around if the future of interactions
with technology is voice then what about
if you can't talk you know are you just
going to be totally cut off of anything
that's going on so what he did is that
he used he used machine learning to
record a sign language with a video
stream he trained that with an algorithm
and then he was basically matching the
video feed with words to be able to send
a request to Alexa so you could ask
things like hello you know what's the
weather and there's a video about it on
YouTube if you want to have a look but I
thought that was a really really
interesting way of using machine
learning for other things than just you
know stuff that insurance companies or
banks would do I think it was it was
quite creative and useful so usually
I'll show a few more examples but I
actually have a surprise for the end of
that talk something that I did last
night which is always a great idea but
so I'm going to move on to the next
section and go back to it later
so we're at the front-end conference so
I guess you might want to know about how
to do that in JavaScript
so let's talk about that now so why
first of all sometimes when you talk to
you devs and I tell them oh I experiment
with machine learning in JavaScript they
kind of like why you know you should do
it in Python it's like I know that
JavaScript is probably not the language
that you go to production with but I
really like the fact that it makes that
particular you know technology
accessible to more people because if you
know that you have to learn about
machine learning and on top of that you
have to learn Python there's a big
probability that you won't even have a
look at it because you don't let you
know not everybody has the luxury of
time and sometimes if you if you know
that you can just learn the Machine
you're next up in in JavaScript then you
might be more susceptible to actually
try because in the end it ends up being
the same thing that you do at work where
you get to learn how to use a specific
framework for example if you're
switching from a reactor to view evil
you already know JavaScript what you
have to know is how to learn view how to
work with you and that's the same thing
with with machine learning is that you
might have to learn a few different
concepts but in the end with JavaScript
frameworks you already know how to write
the code you just have to understand how
the framework itself works a second
reason why I think it's really important
is rapid prototyping so I do a lot of
that on my own time where I get an idea
of something that I want to be old and
well I don't know if it's worth putting
the time and money to actually build
further so I really like using
javascript to just build something
quickly in a couple of hours or a couple
of days and sometimes at work if you
need to convince people to you know give
you a moment you'll give you more time
to build something more robust you can
start you always we always will convince
people more if you actually show them
something and then finally there is
actually a pretty big ecosystem of
frameworks and modules in JavaScript to
do machine learning so you know maybe
you're not really aware about it and
you're like oh I don't want to try
because there's only one framework
there's actually more and more people
and big companies actually putting time
into making the frameworks better so I
think it's a good time to get started so
now that I try to convince you about why
you should do it so what can you do so
you can do three things you can start by
importing a pre an existing pre train
model so it's a model that has been
trained with a lot of data already if
it's a specific
and you can just load it and and you
know reap like reusing otherwise you can
retrain an important model that's my
favorite feature transfer learning so
you kind of do the same as before you
import the pre train model but you can
add your own features and labels and you
can retrain it very quickly and finally
you can define train and run models
entirely in the browser in JavaScript so
that is that is pretty powerful too so
the tools that you can use for that you
might have heard of tensorflow because
this kind of is quite popular by Google
but there's also tend to flood yes some
people actually don't know that there is
the JavaScript version of it you have ml
five that you can try so sometimes
tensorflow has some words that concepts
they're a bit difficult to understand if
you just get started
an ml five year is actually trying to
abstract that so they they make it super
easy to get started there's a lot of
examples so if you know that you don't
have that much time and you just want to
try a few things I would recommend ml
five and then you have more specific
ones like the one in the middle here
it's imagined GS where it's about mixing
machine learning and music so I'm also
really glad we had to talk about web
MIDI because I think you'll be really
cool to mix web MIDI imagine a GIS and
create some kind of weird songs where
you collaborate with algorithms so I
think it's pretty cool of course there's
a lot more that's not it but I think
that would be the let's say the bigger
ones and if you don't really want to
write code but you're still interested
you have the tools that Amazon Microsoft
and Google put together where you can
just bring an API and kind of like play
with machine learning with what they
with what they have so now that I talked
about what you can do well I thought I
would show you because it doesn't really
really make sense if you can't really
see what it's like so let's start with
using a pre trained model so as I said
it's a model that has been trained with
data before and you can just repurpose
it for whatever you want so what I built
for this is an opportunist ichael so I'm
always so I want to get better at
recycling but I always forget what
should go in what bin so I was thinking
can I use machine learning to actually
do that for me so I'm going to show you
how it works
I have it loaded already I just need to
exit all right cool so I'm gonna use its
using an object detection model so I'm
gonna start okay it happens that I have
a bottle of water here okay it's really
good at detecting bottle of water that's
why that's why I use that but I have to
get out of the feet so I have a button
that says is this recyclable I don't
know if the lighting is gonna be great I
have to get out of there yes oh my god
first time he did that anyway so yes
wait so I say yeah it was a bottle and
then I have it is recyclable throw it in
the yellow bin so you can start again
with different objects and stuff like
that and you can have a bit of fun so
I'm gonna close this one and go back to
my right alright so let's look at the
code to build something like that it's
really like super quick so you start by
importing a model so the model that I
use these coco SSD and object detection
model and you import tensorflow
you start by loading the model to be
able to use it and then you just use
some of tends to flow methods to look at
all the pixels in the camera and then
you have some kind of like built-in
functions just to rescale the data in
the way that the model is expecting it
so you know I'm not going to dive into
that too much I think it's something
that you should look into that's more
technical and it would be a bit boring
to explain how it works
and once the you kind of reprocess the
image to the right format that it's
expecting you can just give up a
processed image to the model that you
loaded and you get the predictions like
for that first feature that's basically
just it after the rest about telling you
which finish should go to that was just
hard coded at the moment but if there
was an API of you know once we go in
what beam you would just ping that API
based on what has been recognized in the
video feed also by the way it was
supposed to meet more of a mobile demo
so it would be you know I'm not gonna
walk around with my computer being yeah
but the second thing that you can do is
transfer learning so as I said it's my
favorite so what I built for that is
something that I called the teachable
keyboard so I am interested in seeing
how machine learning can use with I can
be used with accessibility so I wanted
to build a demo around seeing if you
could communicate
with the movements of your head so just
kind of like motion tracking in the
browser okay so I'm here yeah you can
see quite fine okay so the feed is gonna
be really really super small but there's
a reason for that that I'll explain
later this part of the app is actually
that was just so you have a visual thing
but what's important is coming after so
there's a video feed and I have buttons
of the classes that I want to Train so
I'm just gonna be a bit more okay so I'm
going to the right I'm going to the left
I'm gonna go down and I'm gonna stay
neutral I'm just going to test that it's
working down okay it's struggling a bit
so I'm gonna go back look that's right
okay wait neutral I don't know more
I just forgot which way is left so
that's great and right okay okay that's
a bit better and the part of the app
that I like is this one and you're just
able to move around and I realized I
actually wanted to launch it locally
because I wanted to write something I
wanted to write la bus but that's not
gonna work because yeah I launched the
wrong demo but anyway you can do that I
think that did the lighting just change
because now it's not recognized matters
anyway so I can just work go right left
and neutral and I wanted to right okay
it's not recognizing writing but as you
can see I was able to basically give my
own features and labels to the model
preloaded in like 10 seconds so well
that emily is not really working well
but usually it's fine
and you can just write stuff by moving
your head like I could just be like that
and it would work as well so let's look
at the code quickly alright so for this
there is a little bit more code but
actually not that much you start by
importing another detection model that
you know this time I switched to a
mobile net that's a popular one as well
you import tensorflow and then you have
to import a classifier so we are
constants main classifier because what
you're going to have to do is re trained
on top of the model that you loaded then
you just declare some
so the number of classes is well it was
for me but it can be in anything because
you have I have right left down neutral
so the image size of 227 this is why the
camera feed was super small the more
pixels the longer it's gonna take to
retrain so I think in their example they
said you know just set it to 227 because
it's the way that mobile net was trained
so if you add features on top of it it
kind of has to have the same size you
could have a full screen and then kind
of like reprocess the image but that
would take that would take a bit longer
and the K value for K nn I don't have
the time to explain how the algorithm
actually works but that's the value that
works for me but it would change over
time then what you do is you kind of
like create your classifiers who
instantiate a k-9 classifier you load
your module you do the same thing as
before where you read the pixels from
the webcam but what you do here is you
kind of merge the new pixels the new
features and labels to the mobile net
that you loaded so that then you can add
that to the classifier that you just
created and in the end predict the
classes based on what you the variable
that you set at the beginning and in the
end you can dispose of the images
because once the classifier is retrained
with your own samples you don't need to
to keep the data anymore
so that was for transfer learning and
finally doing everything in JavaScript
so for that particular demo I'm always
will be worried because I don't wanna
make anybody uncomfortable and I don't
want to go against the code of conduct
so okay I'm just gonna say it so I built
a wheelie detector but I know that if
English is not your first language I
know that some people don't know what
wheelie is so a wheelie is a penis but
it I'm not talking about images nobody
wants pictures I'm talking about
drawings and the reason why I think I me
the reason why I did that otherwise I
look really weird so what I wanted to do
is I wanted to create something else
where I wanted to have this kind of
collaboration tool on the web where
anybody could just join a page and row
and like you know you would have people
drawing everywhere and I wanted to use
that then for a hardware project that
would be life and I was thinking if I
let people draw stuff on the internet
like of course they're gonna draw
Willy's and there is no way I'm not
gonna
down 24/7 trying to figure out and
remove his people's ro beliefs so I was
thinking well machine learning can help
me do that so I'm just going to show you
quickly
I think the canvas is gonna be a bit
small as well oh that's actually okay
first of all again because I would have
to reprocess the image it would take
longer and also when I do demos I don't
really want to throw a massive wheelie
on screen so that's just gonna be a
small one so yeah that's not right
it's not even the worst part of this
talk that comes after so so I'm gonna
draw a Kendall to start with mm-hmm I'm
gonna predict and it says not Willie
we're all good that's good so now I'm
clear let me just mind my drawing skills
you know and Willie so let me just clear
that now so at the moment so it's
working right and it's really cool
because I built everything from scratch
so it means AG I learned too low
at the moment in only only it only works
with candles and Willie's because that's
what I trained it for but the purpose in
the end would be to have a lot more
drawings so let's talk about the steps
that I took to build this and this is
where the worst part comes so you start
with data collection and so here on the
right that's an open source that I said
so it's um it's a quick draw so Google
has put together an open source that I
said where they have they had this kind
of like game online where they asked
people to draw stuff and you highlight
you have ten seconds to draw a crocodile
and they actually saved everybody's
inputs to make it open source for that
kind of projects probably not for my
kind of projects before all the kind of
projects and the thing is that I there's
no way I can recognize whatever really
is if it's never seen one before so I
had to build my own data set know that
many images I think quick draw has 100
like two hundred thousand samples of
course I did not draw that many I think
I drew about two hundred which was
already very too much for me and okay so
that's the first step you have to start
with data this light then you have to do
data processing
and what the processing is in the quick
TRO that I set it's actually really like
a smart talk I mean I know I'm kidding
but it's actually I had to do that
anyway so in the quit role that I set
every picture is 28 by 28 pixels because
the smaller it is the faster it's going
to be to Train but when I drew on a
webpage when I save the images it was
basically 200 by 200 so for it to fit
with the quick-draw that I said I had to
do that are processing and resize them
and kind of like crop them so that it
would look a bit the same as the rest of
the data set so you have to do that as
well when you do things by yourself then
you have to split the data set between
training and test so you use 80% of your
whole data set for training so you give
that to the algorithm to generate the
model and then you have to keep 20% of
it for test data and what is what you
use that for is that when the model is
generated your date your test data is
already labeled so you already know
really or Kendall so you're gonna give
that to the model and if it predicts the
right thing if the accuracy is good then
you think you know that your model is
pretty good otherwise you kind of like
RISP it but basically then after you
pick your algorithm there's no kind of
like real purpose of choosing the
algorithm before but I used a
convolution on your network because well
reading about this I know that it deals
well with images
you know I'm dealing with images so that
sounded pretty right then you do what we
call parameter tuning so when you ask
the model to predict new samples you
don't just give you the data you
actually have to tweak quite a few
parameters it's more of an art than a
science you'll never get it right the
first time
then you train then you get your
prediction and based on the amount of
accuracy you actually repeat these steps
and you can actually repeat them
sometimes quite quite a lot okay good
sample so this is I really took like a
small small portion because there's a
lot more but I'm just going to talk to
you about the steps so you have to
display your training set between
training data and test data you just
create tensors and this is where if you
want to have something that's to be
easier you should go to ml 5 rather than
tensorflow
but so tensors are basically arrays of
that contains your data and it's shaped
in a certain way to train machine
learning models basic
so you have trained the functions to
train and test then you create your
model and this is where I'm not going to
spend too much time because the
documentation is pretty good they have
people working full-time on that and
they would probably explain it a lot
better but you can add different layers
to neural networks layers is the same as
parameter tuning you kind of tweak that
and you see how it changes the accuracy
of of your predictions and then so you
get your training data you call the fit
function to give the features and labels
to the model with the parameters of
batch size and stuff like that then you
guessed your test data and so when the
model is fit then it's it's ready and
you give the features and labels of your
examples to the model and based on the
prediction you can see the accuracy it's
like if I know that I gave it a candle
did it give me the prediction candle so
yeah there is more lines but in terms of
steps that's it it's you split your your
data you create the model you train it
and then you run the prediction with
your test data a few limits there's
always a minute so you need a large
amount of data except if you use pre
trained model so sometimes it there are
a few open source pre-trained model but
sometimes it just won't do it won't be
something like that you'd want to use
for your for your purpose you don't have
to build your own and you need quite a
large amount like thousands and
thousands of samples it can take a lot
of time to train your own model so
depending on what you're doing if you're
dealing with images it's even longer
there's some really cool stuff that
people do but I think there's a time
where I wanted to have an experiment
with art and it had to be trained for
eight hours and you wait and you wait
and sometimes they don't tell you it
doesn't tell you that it's gonna fail
until you've waited seven hours so so
you can take quite a lot of time it's
always good to remember think about the
mobile experience because what I didn't
tell you is that some free training
model are very heavy the one that I used
for the recycling app was 15 megabytes I
didn't know that at first you know I
just wrote like import but then I looked
at the chrome dev tools and I saw that
it was loading and loading and loading
and I was just like this is horrible so
on Wi-Fi you know maybe that's fine it's
still gonna be a bit slow but it's okay
but if you think about
gee and so this is gonna be really slow
and also you're kind of taking you know
sighs in the data plan of your user so
you don't really want to do that
liability is an important one depending
on what you'll want to build if you're
working for an insurance or bank and
using machine learning to predict if
somebody should have a loan or not or
fraud detection if you accuse somebody
wrongly and they sue you you have to be
able to explain why a model made a
certain decision you can't just like
give the responsibility to the model and
then say oh well I don't know it just
said no you know so that's that wouldn't
work you would be actually sued and you
have to be able to explain what's going
on which is a difficult thing and then
finally but it needs to be mentioned
bias and ethics that's a really really
interesting topic actually even if you
don't want to code in machine learning I
would really recommend looking into that
particular topic because I feel like ml
can really help us understand our own
biases and actually help us get better
so I always mentioned that algorithms
are not biased we are and sometimes you
read articles when people say oh Google
created a 60s algorithm and the thing is
like it's just a piece of math in code
like it's not sexist but his sexist is
the data that it was fed with and that
data actually comes from us so I think
trying to push the responsibility on a
piece of code is a bit silly I think we
should just take responsibility and be
like well actually all that content is
something that each and every one of us
is actually creating one example of that
is I don't know if yeah that's all right
so there was an example a few years ago
with Google Translate where general
neutral language like Turkish was
translated to English which is more
gendered so words like hard working and
lazy kind of became gendered ways like
he's hardworking and she's lazy and
she's a cook and he's an engineer you
know that's not the algorithm that just
decided to do that it's because the
content that was fed to train a Google
Translate is something that we all right
so yes I would just you know even just
that topic is pretty interesting oh
that's the surprise time okay so as I
said I built something that I've never
shown before so this is going to be a
little present for you exclusive I
haven't shared it because it's not
finished I'm pretty excited
about it though and I thought you know
I'm actually is it's a demo that I'm
working on for another talk so if you
hate it you have to tell me so I don't
waste my time
I keep working it but okay so let me
remember so I have to I need to talk
about the inspiration for that demo so
usually I show this example so this is
this is not in JavaScript but this is a
project where Minko Java all right I was
probably either be said but he used the
webcam feed and machine learning to
recognize movements and apply that to a
game of MORTAL KOMBAT
so I really like this example I already
thought it was a really cool way of
using machine learning the thing that I
thought though is like well you have to
be in front of the webcam so knowing a
bit of computer vision if the lighting
is wrong so you can't play by night you
know like if you are just a little bit
out of the camera it's not gonna
recognize it properly so I decided to
kind of add a little twist to it like
make my own version kind of so let me
figure out alright so I have the
terminal and and we gonna cook this home
because it doesn't matter okay I have
two minutes left so that's enough I need
to just
yes I'm gonna get out because I'm not
using the camera I mean the one on the
right on the red okay all right hey it
[ __ ] up all right wait wait wait wait
wait damn it yes
so I have three different ones so I'm
going to try the other one and I think
it's like [ __ ] I [ __ ] up again let
me try I really want to it worked well
in my hotel room okay I think I'm going
too fast so it doesn't get enough
alright I really like that way so much
fun yeah so I'm the ocean that to
anybody so if you think it was really
rubbish please let me know because then
I you will avoid me being a really
embarrassed at all the conference but
the way it works is I'm actually not
gonna tell you how it works because what
if you want to know you have to follow
me now no but I mean the talk is not
ready and I think it's like it's a it's
a whole topic so I'm not gonna go into
details but I will share the code and
blog post and more videos when I kind of
like make it a bit better but basically
I'm almost done I just have a few
resources if you want oh by the way just
a detail about the previous you know the
motor will combat stuff everything in
JavaScript there is absolutely no other
language everything is JavaScript
written from scratch and yeah that was
pretty fun to work with so here as I
said you know there's a pretty big
ecosystem of tools and that's not even
the entire list there's more and more
everyday useful links if you want some
courses or if you want to watch stuff
about the ethics and governments
governance of AI at MIT that was a
really interesting video and there's a
few links around using machine learning
for more creative and fun experiments
and finally as I said if you can't be
bothered to gather your own data there
are actually open-source data sets and
free train models so if you want to get
started that's pretty that can be pretty
quick so that was it for today hopefully
you know it's maybe makes a bit more
sense and maybe you're a bit more
excited you don't have
at all but at least now you know that
was more like my main goal but thank you
very much
[Applause]